bonjour vous êtes bien dans un gentes
dames badass mais petit message
supplémentaire pour vous dire de rester
à la fin de la vidéo
en effet je vous parlerai de time warp
khaimah web série d'histoires de voyage
dans le temps dont la saison 2 est en
cours de financement via ulule ou que
via financement participatif et donc
pour ça on aurait besoin d'un petit coup
de main de votre part pour que le
financement réussissent mais tout ça je
vous en parlerai en fin de vidéo donc
place à la norme aux arts et à bientôt
bonjour si je vous dis mozart je pense
que c'est un nom qui vous parle en tout
cas c'est un nom qui me parle bien sûr
c'était quand même le nom de mon chat
mais au train célèbre compositeur et un
chat exceptionnel le nom de mozart
désigne aussi nannerl la soeur méconnu
de wolfgang qui aurait tellement mérité
de rester dans les mémoires
maria anna mozart surnommé downadup et
dès le 30 juillet 1751 à salzbourg cinq
ans avant son petit frère paul quand
leur père leopold mozart est un
concertiste joueurs de clavecin et de
violon ou services du prince archevêque
de salzbourg le couple mozart à cinq
autres enfants mais seuls madoff et
volcom survivre durant leur enfance les
deux enfants sont très proches allant
jusqu'à s'inventer leur propre langage
se créer leur univers imaginaire lorsque
papa mozart commence à enseigner le
piano à nador car leurs sept ans
wolfgang se trouve à ses côtés
wolfgang et nador montre très vite un
potentiel impressionnant
ils sont capable de transposer en othe
n'importe quel air de le jouer les
pièces les plus difficile d'improviser
leur père mais ils en mettent donc à
travers les villes d'europe pour qu'il
se produise dieu leur a donné de tels
talents que je serai contraint même si
ce n'était mon devoir paternelle de tout
sacrifier à leur bonne éducation
chaque instant perdu let a jamais écrite
il lors de leur première tournée nannerl
à 11 ans et wolfgang 6 les deux enfants
enchante tous les publics qu'ils
rencontrent du cours princières en
concert privé tout le monde s'extasie
quand mozart est là on raconte qu'ils
sont capables de jouer du clavecin les
yeux fermés le club qui est recouvert
d'un drap ou avec un seul doigt
wolfgang et plus en vue étant plus jeune
menad armes partage toujours l'estrade
avec lui jouant ou chantant leur père
écrit aussi à son propos ma petite fille
joue les pièces les plus difficiles que
nous avons avec une incroyable précision
étant d'excellence ce que je veux dire
est que ma petite fille bien qu'elle n'a
que 12 ans est l'un des musiciens les
plus talentueux d'europe
son talent est aussi vanté par le comte
charles band in the hands of qui
assistent à l'huile de leur
représentation
le petit garçon de sa ce beau
et sa soeur joue du clavecin le pauvre
petit garçon joue merveilleusement c'est
un enfant spirituel vivant charmant le
jeu de sa soeur est magistral et ils
applaudissaient j'entendis plus tard
dans une lettre que personne ne joue
aussi bien ses compositions que sa soeur
nador les non seulement une excellente
interprète mais elle compose des pièces
wolfgang l'encouragent beaucoup et joe
notamment l'une de ses oeuvres lors d'un
concert révélant seulement à la fin
qu'elle a été écrite par sa soeur cela
provoque la colère de leur père qui
interdit dès lors un âne earl d'écrire
de la musique car une femme ne peut pas
devenir compositrice c'est comme ça car
oui vous l'aurez deviné la grande
malédiction de nador et sa famille et
surtout son père qui bride son talent à
18 ans elle est en âge de se marier et
s'il était mignon qu'une petite fille se
produisent en concert c'est un peu moins
accepter de la part d'une jeune femme
son père se concentre alors uniquement
sur la carrière de wolfgang il refuse
qu'une année en apprennent le violon
arrête de l'emmener en tournée
maintenant je dois rester à la maison et
donne des cours de piano pour financer
les tournées de son frère ses rêves sont
brisés et elle commence une dépression
cette situation éloigne le frère dont la
carrière décolle et qui part souvent en
tournée et la soeur rester à salzbourg
surtout après le mariage de wolfgang
card and her déteste sa femme
la norme désiré même se marier avec le
capitaine france dit paul dont elle est
très amoureuse mais son père refuse
cette union vous propose même à sa soeur
de venir le rejoindre à vienne avec son
capitaine pour vivre leur amour hors
mariage mais elle se résigne son père me
philippe houzé en 1784 le magistrat jo
ann baptiste france bershawn semaine aux
aveugles déjà père de cinq enfants
de cette union d'anor là trois enfants
dont un mur en bas âge elle reste à la
maison et s'occupe de léopold ii
jeannette et des enfants de son mari
leur apprenant la musique mais aucun
doute devenir musicien même s'il n'avait
que des contacts bref avec son frère ses
lettres reste plein d'affection
la dernière lettre de 25 ans gars sa
soeur montreux même qu'il tente un
rapprochement avec elle même s'il avait
aussi un service ave une bande et soeur
chérie qui auraient raison d'être fâché
contre moi mais le sera plus encore
lorsque la diligence tu aura apporté mes
dernières compositions pour piano au nom
cela remettra j'espère les choses en
place comme tu seras convaincu que je
souhaite vraiment chaque jour toutes
sortes de choses agréables pour toi tu
me pardonneras d'arriver un peu
avec mes voeux de bonnes fêtes ma chère
soeur tu ne peux pas douter que j'ai
fort à faire et tu sais fort bien que je
suis quelque peu paresseux pour écrire
des lettres
tu ne m'en voudra donc pas si je t'écris
rarement je dois maintenant te demander
quelque chose
j'aimerais que hayden me prête pour
quelques temps les partitions de ces
deux mais sans tout y est les graduelle
qui la composent et invite le à venir et
j'oublie mes nouvelles compositions
le trio le quatuor ne lui déplairait pas
à dieu soeur chérie
dès que j'aurai rassembler de nouvelles
musiques je te les enverrait je suis à
jamais ton frère sincère wolfgang
amadeus mozart la mort de wolf gang en
1791 est l'occasion pour nannerl de
trouver un nouveau but
elle honore la mémoire de son frère en
rassemblant les compositions et les
lettres qu'ils s'échangeaient depuis des
années lorsqu'un biographe la contacter
en 1792 pour qu'elles répondent à
quelques questions
elle ne parle que de leur enfance et de
leur tournée et ne dit rien de la
carrière de wolfgang à partir du moment
où leurs chemins se séparent la parution
d'une autre biographie en 1800 lui fait
toutefois prendre conscience de la fin
de vie difficiles de son frère
la biographie de pêcher le professeur du
match est complètement raviver mes
sentiments fraternels envers mon frère
si ardemment aimé que souvent je
sanglotait ne m'étant aperçu qu'il ya
peu la triste condition dans laquelle il
se trouvait à la mort de son mari elle
recommence à donner des cours de piano
elle devient aveugle vers 1825 est mort
le 29 octobre 1829 à 78 aucune oeuvre
signée d'elle de nous est parvenue dans
une lettre de son frère qui répondent à
une composition qu'elle lui avait
envoyée il s'exclame ma chère soeur je
suis admiratif que vous composiez si
bien en un mot le morceau que vous avez
écrit il est beau c'est aussi qu'elle a
orchestré la première symphonie de son
frère puisque nanar l'écrivait les
compositions de wolfgang à sa place
lorsqu'il était trop jeune pour les
mettre par écrit
il est possible que certains des
morceaux attribué à volcan soit en
réalité d'elle sa vie a été racontée
dans un film nader la soeur de mozart et
dans une pièce de théâtre les odeurs
rose art dans son roman une chambre à
soi
virginia wolf imagine un instant qu'une
soeur à shakespeare aussi doué que son
frère et toutes les difficultés qu'elle
aurait rencontré pour faire connaître
son talent si elle avait connu
l'existence d'un énorme aux arêtes
n'aurait pas eu besoin de fiction pour
étayer son propos
mais à l'époque où virginia écrivait
nador l'avait déjà depuis longtemps
sombré dans
si ces travaux sont probablement perdu
pour toujours on peut au moins faire
ressurgir son existence dans cette vidéo
et s'imaginer en écoutant quelques
pièces de wolfgang que sa soeur se
trouve derrière certaines idées j'espère
que cette vidéo vous a plu pour ma part
j'étais assez sur le cul quand j'ai
découvert l'existence de dernière mozart
quand même mozart a une soeur aussi doué
qu'elle ait personne le sait c'est fou
alors n'hésitez pas à partager cette
vidéo pour faire connaître son histoire
et a commenté contribuer au financement
des vidéos sur type i knew you type si
vous le souhaitez et si vous le pouvez
bien sûr et on se retrouve très bientôt
pour un chronique de profs
merci beaucoup elle ne partait pas tout
de suite
comme je le disais je vais vous parler
un petit peu de time warp donc tu as
moins c'est une web série d'histoires et
de voyage dans le temps dans la saison
il est sorti en 2010 neuf sur cette
chaîne dont vous pouvez aller la
retrouver
donc dans cette série on retrouve les
personnages de mes chroniques de profs
aliénor lucrecia et dans la saison mais
ne l'expliqué bave pourquoi ils se
retrouvent au 21ème siècle est donc là
j'ai écrit cette saison 2 qui est
beaucoup plus ambitieuse en termes
d'épisodes de durée de scénario aussi
j'aimerais beaucoup essayé de développer
les personnages de créer de nouvelles à
de nouveaux enjeux forcément des
nouveaux méchants
bref ça peut être vraiment très très
bien donc comme pour la saison une on
passe par un financement participatif
pour la créer pour la saison et n'en
avait réussi à rassembler 3000 euros ce
qui nous avait pas vraiment permis
d'être confortable dans seront réalisés
c'était vraiment bien pour la saison 2
qu'elle est un petit peu plus ambitieuse
il nous faudrait cinq mille euros
donc il y à asnières et l'uil qui sera
partagé en fin de vidéo qui va
s'afficher ici même et qui sera dans la
description et peut-être même encore
commentaires il sera partout partout et
donc ce lien et l'uil n'hésitez pas à
aller le consulter à le partager
c'est très très important parce que le
partage ça peut faire plein plein de
choses vraiment et pour faire que d'être
la série un maximum parce que peut-être
que vous vous
voulez pas vous pouvez pas donner mais
peut-être que vos voisins peuvent et si
vous voulez et pouvait donner en plus
alors là c'est vraiment merveilleux et
donc un grand merci à tout ce que vous
pourrez faire qui aidera à faire
connaître un petit peu ce projet il
reste 36 jours de financement est pour
l'instant on a atteint un quart du
financement
donc il ya de l'espoir mais il faut
vraiment y aller à fond parce que les
premiers jours sont toujours les jours
où on récolte le plus et ensuite il faut
continuer voilà donc merci beaucoup
j'espère que mon message je n'étais pas
un peu trop long je me perds souvent
dans mes explications mais c'est
vraiment un projet qui me tient à coeur
et va dans tous les cas on se retrouve
sinon le mois prochain pour un chronique
de profs et bien sûr au cours de la
campagne d'un mois qui aura d'autres
petites vidéos qui apparaîtront ici et
qu'ils seront plus en lien avec telle
marque avec l'histoire mais mais vous
qui êtes là pour l'histoire je ne vous
oublie pas voilà merci beaucoup et à
bientôt
[Musique]